[Música]
aquí comienza a ellos hoy de france24
qué pasa con los hijos de las mujeres
que perdieron la vida víctimas de la
violencia machista en bolivia como en el
resto de países esta vez la pregunta que
abre la puerta de la revictimización y
de un círculo de violencias que está
lejos de acabar cuando una mujer es
asesinada por un feminicida ese es
nuestro tema de hoy
la violencia machista en bolivia causo
108 feminicidios y casi 47 mil denuncias
de agresiones en 2021 con sus madres
muertas y en algunos casos con los
padres en prisión los niños en medio de
las violencias quedaron desprotegidos
algunos a cargo de sus abuelos u otros
familiares que han intentado cuidarlos y
sobrevivir en la precariedad las cifras
crecen cada año y de momento no hay una
solución del estado para estos casos
vamos a ver el reporte de meriva acá
nuestra corresponsable en bolivia
verdad en bolivia
viviana mal que hija de maría quispe
murió en diciembre tras pasar siete
meses en estado de coma persistente
luego de que su pareja le causara
lesiones graves
justicia por qué
mi hija tiene 28 en conocer cómo se va a
desparecer a beth en esto si acaso no
tiene el reciente de su avant con la
escalada de violencia en contra de las
mujeres en bolivia ha dejado desde el
2013 según una comisión del parlamento
un total de 997 feminicidios y cerca de
350 huérfanos menores de 12 años como
los hijos de viviana que ahora maría
debe criar y educar y así como tener voy
a crear estos y mis hijos también me va
a llorar me llegas muy ayer dio tivo
estar manteniendo después colegios
también no estar poniendo los nietos de
maría cuentan por ahora con ella pero en
muchos casos otros huérfanos pasan de
mano en mano hasta hallar un tutor
dentro o fuera de sus familias un abrir
y cerrar de ojos pero lynch han quedado
sin madre sin padre y hay familias que
hay veces no se adquieren hacer cargo de
los sobrinos o de los nietos la
defensoría del pueblo está preocupada
porque muchos huérfanos terminan en
hogares estatales sin la asistencia
necesaria
abandonan la escuela y trabajan en las
calles por este motivo ha pedido al
parlamento una ley para dar ayuda
económica y psicológica pero no ha
tenido respuesta lastimosamente este
proyecto no ha tenido un avance
significativo aunque vemos que hay una
comprensión de que la problemática tiene
una necesidad de urgencia en su
tratamiento con hogares destruidos y un
estado sin soluciones los hijos de las
víctimas de feminicidio viven en el
desamparo maría y su familia no quieren
que la muerte de viviana quede impune
108 feminicidios ocurrieron en 2021 pero
sólo 30 de los agresores obtuvieron
sentencia
y para conversar sobre el tema está en
ella soy estela quintana ella es
fundadora y representante de la
organización de familias de víctimas en
busca de justicia bolivia estela también
es tía de una víctima de feminicidio
abigail quintana quien fue asesinada en
2019 por eso creó la organización con la
intención de ayudar a quienes buscan
justicia por los feminicidios de sus
familiares este la bienvenida gracias y
en qué situación quedan los hijos de las
mujeres que pierden la vida por
feminicidio
muchas gracias por la cobertura querida
angela realmente es preocupante lo que
estamos viviendo en bolivia y quizás en
muchos otros países no muchos huérfanos
están quedando prácticamente abandonados
como acaban de mencionar en la nota es
cierto que los niños pasan a la segundas
personas ya sean nativos o en este caso
específico de viviana marc que fue
totalmente golpeada y después de un
sufrimiento de varios meses en el
hospital y abandonada fallece y deja a
dos niños huérfanos y la que se encarga
después la mamá de la tercera edad
entonces eso es preocupante y es más
quiero mencionar que nosotros como
organización habíamos presentado un
anteproyecto de ley pidiendo al gobierno
en el año
2020 ya en el mes de junio estamos
hablando de más de un año y medio una
renta vitalicia para este sector
para que los familiares tengan un
ingreso y así puedan sacar adelante a
estos niños porque imagínense una tía
que luego se tenga que encargar de
aumentar la familia
hola por el asesinato de la hermana
entonces realmente es casi imposible
sacarlos adelante y muchos quedan en el
olvido no incluso en los hogares quedan
abandonados y pues estamos pidiendo por
todas estas víctimas por todas estas
familias que de una vez entrantes de
anteproyecto de ley que ha sido
presentado
estela existen un soporte de tipo
psicológico existe algún tipo de ayuda
hoy en día como están las cosas
lamentablemente yo como familiar de una
víctima y con el resto de la de las
de las personas que forman parte de
nuestra organización que son familiares
directas de las víctimas y los niños
realmente no tenemos ningún apoyo ningún
apoyo ni siquiera psicológico para
sostener es más nuestra organización es
la que
las contiene ayudan mucho con algunas
profesionales psicólogas que nos apoyan
y en la cuarentena ha sido mucho más
duro porque hemos tenido que recibir
terapias e incluso por vía zoom vía
internet para llegar a la mayoría de la
población afectada y es donde más duro
nos pega este dolor porque es un dolor
tan grande que no podemos no podemos
esperar yo le digo como como días de una
jovencita de 18 años que ha sido
brutalmente golpeada abigail quintana y
asesinada de la manera más cruel por un
menor de edad
mire estamos hablando de la dificultad
que padecen las familias los niños
cuando pierden a su madre por
feminicidio pero qué pasa cuando además
el feminicida es el padre
si justamente
quedan en total abandono no porque
hemos visto que los feminicidas en un
porcentaje menor se han suicidado y el
otro porcentaje ha sido sentenciado y
parte prácticamente los niños quedan en
total abandono como acababa de decirle
con algunos familiares que se hacen
cargo pero es necesaria esta ayuda a
esta renta vitalicia de parte del
gobierno para poderlo sacar adelante a
los nudos yo le preguntaba sobre sobre
las maternidades y las paternidades tan
difíciles en estos casos
más hacia esta pregunta la muerte
violenta de los padres o de la madre es
un dolor que se puede curar que adulto
podemos esperar cuando de niño fue una
víctima más de feminicidio
realmente es una cadena de violencia
porque a su mayoría los niños han visto
como como el padre asesinado a la mamá
entonces es necesaria esta ayuda
psicológica este soporte pero no la
recibimos no la reciben los niños no nos
reciben está esta ayuda y más adelante
pues estos niños pueden crear cierto
resentimiento y
se van desviando no por eso se necesita
se necesita esa contención para los
niños y encaminarlos también para para
que mañana sean niños de bien jóvenes de
bien y puedan superar ese ese mal
momento ese dolor que han que han
padecido no al perder a sus padres y
quedarse solos y además otra gran
problemática es que no se conoce la
magnitud de este fenómeno hace falta un
registro oficial de datos sobre la
cantidad de menores que perdieron a sus
madres por violencia machista se está
haciendo algo por conocer la verdadera
magnitud del problema
la verdad es que en bolivia no la verdad
no porque solamente son datos que se
están llevando de los hechos violentos
que se
suscitan en las ciudades pero en el área
rural pues no tenemos un reporte exacto
de cuántas víctimas fueron y cuántos
niños víctimas también de feminicido
quedaron huérfanos
y además una noticia reciente es que el
gobierno declaró el año 2022 como el año
de la despatriarcalización es de alguna
ayuda que hayan hecho esta declaratoria
realmente tiene efectos en los derechos
de las mujeres y por lo tanto en los
derechos de sus hijos y de sus
familiares
acaban de declarar
pero no estamos viendo no hemos sido
debilitadas
al programa de cómo van a desarrollar y
cómo y cómo van a llevar a cabo no
porque hace dos años atrás también se
declaró la lucha frontal contra la
violencia con la anterior
gobierno pero no pasa nada también
quiero mencionar que hubo dos comisiones
en el año 2019 para poder
ayudar y encontrar los cuellos de
botella de los hechos violentos que
estaba viviendo bolivia y el año pasado
también pero estas comisiones sólo
concluyen que es necesario que
incrementen más funcionarios públicos
para que puedan atender estos temas de
violencia pero yo le digo que esa no es
la solución aquí el tema de la impunidad
está creando más violencia
por el s da sentencias estela ya nos
estamos quedando sin tiempo pero quería
hacerle una última pregunta y es ya
desde el plano personal usted como mujer
como familiar como víctima también
colateral del feminicidio cómo es el
proceso de sanación que debe hacerse
después de una pérdida así
lamentablemente yo tengo que decirle que
ni siquiera nosotras con mi hermana
porque abigail eran la hija única no
recibimos ninguna ayuda psicológica
ningún tipo de contención y nosotras
esencias familiares nos vamos apoyando
por eso es que nuestra lucha continúa en
contra de la violencia y estamos
trabajando ya en programas de prevención
desde nuestra organización imagínense
nosotros como organización civil estamos
emprendiendo estos estos proyectos
pues le agradezco mucho estela para
usted solamente deseos de recuperación y
también es deseos de que sea exitosa su
iniciativa gracias también a nuestros
televidentes por estar una vez más con
nosotros nos vemos próximamente en ella
soy
[Música]